maintenant marc meneau et michel
chevalet à vous
oui eh bien eh bien nous allons toujours
des problèmes de micros nous allons donc
effectivement joué avec un ordinateur en
direct sur ce plateau y est qui et je
vous présenterai thaler est avec nous
vous voyez il y à là ce que l'on appelle
un micro ordinateur vous savez que les
ordinateurs ont subi des cures
d'amaigrissement ces dernières années
ils ont diminué de taille
en voici un il s'appelle et paul et paul
en anglais signifie une pomme donc voilà
ce mini ordinateur et avec marc hé bien
il vient programme on va jouer ni plus
ni moins qu'à la guerre des étoiles a
envoyé les points blancs sur votre écran
ce sont des étoiles ensuite ici où se
trouve mon doigt ça c'est ma soucoupe
volante et de l'autre côté il y à la
soucoupe volante de marque et avec marc
et bien nous allons jouer grâce à ses
deux boutons nous allons et bien jouer à
la guerre des étoiles c'est à dire je
vais viser marque alors je me déplace
pour ficeler une bonne chose parce que
je compte suivre également la lutte et
toi alors je tire en direction d'autres
marques y est on a un petit problème là
là on y va venir notre secours manque
d'énergie pour faire décoller les
soucoupes
alors je vous rappelle que ye le jeune
garçon qui aima à 16 ans il est en 3e et
seuil et qui manipule ses donateurs il
fait partie d'un club qui s'appelle le
microtel alors y est on y va et en
quelque sorte vous voyez qu'il sait
manipuler jongler qu'un ordinateur en ce
moment et est en train de rappeler le
programme vous savez qu'un ordinateur
travail avec un programme et on rappelle
le programme alors je vous de montrer
quelque chose vous voyez ça cette petite
carte que j'ai à la main a marre vous
voyez cette petite carte c'est
l'équivalent d'un 45 tours c'est le 45
tours des ordinateurs et sur ce 45 tours
il y a
le programme de travail de l'ordinateur
c'est à dire la bataille des étoiles
oui
ou bien il ya des problèmes
[Rires]
électroniques new shoes a toujours des
tours être pas de narnia l'iton fort
voilà alors l'ordinateur est en train de
nous trahir
ça c'est le rôle du goulet du direct et
à chaque fois qu'on les ouvre alors la
l'ordinateur cafouille complètement
regarder sur l'écran en ce moment où
étais tu qui s'y retrouve plus qu'est ce
qui se passe il ya plus d étoiles le
programme est sorti des sabots qu'un on
a perdu le programme de l'ordinateur ni
richesse à programme à la natte et
malheureusement ce n'est pas le bon bon
c'est pas grave
marc ce n'est pas grave
comme cette émission dont tout cet après
midi est consacré ils ont à la science
eh bien nous allons voir différentes
opérations sur valeurs
j'ai fait des découvertes pour les voir
un train solaire moi je vous propose aux
marques
on va marquer une petite peau est
d'accord dié qui est un expert dans en
la matière va nous remettre ça au point
et après on jouera à nouveau à la
bataille des étoiles
[Musique]